aferrándose a la tumba de su hijo alan
abate se rehúsa a dejarlo van a tener
que pasar sobre mi cadáver si quieren
sacar los restos de mi hijo de acá yo
misma será enterrada aquí en al yusufi
ya el cementerio se ha convertido en el
último punto álgido del este de
jerusalén las autoridades israelíes
planean construir un parque al lado del
lugar sin amenazar a ninguna tumba
autorizada según lo que dicen pero las
obras de construcción a centímetros de
los ataúdes generaron pánico entre los
familiares estas acciones no son
aceptables son una violación contra el
cementerio y la santidad de nuestros
fallecidos y sus restos
según los acuerdos de oslo el este de
jerusalén sería la capital de un estado
independiente palestino un plan que se
ve más lejano que nunca mientras israel
planea incrementar los asentamientos en
cisjordania
eeuu condenó la última expansión
y estamos preocupados por la publicación
de las licitaciones el domingo para
construir 1300 residencias en varios
asentamientos de cisjordania nos
oponemos rotundamente a la expansión de
estos asentamientos que son
completamente inconsistentes con los
esfuerzos para disminuir las tensiones y
asegurar la calma
esta es una de las declaraciones más
duras por parte de los eeuu en los
últimos años bajo el mandato de donald
trump los asentamientos y las anexiones
pasaron desapercibidas conforme crecen
las tensiones aumentan también las
críticas internacionales la onu ha
reiterado su posición de que todos los
asentamientos israelíes son ilegales
bajo la ley internacional